Okay.
Let's begin
a,
we continue,
uh,
Monday's a look at a Goldman Sachs and Goldman Sachs,
a role in the world of financial capitalism.
Um,
and
as on Monday,
we have my good friend Paulos the Noni with us.
Uh,
he remarked after Monday's class that he didn't get a single nasty question or
gesture or anything of that nature,
uh,
here.
And then he spoke to his,
uh,
chairman Lloyd Lloyd Blankfein Blankfein who has been going around IB schools
talking lately and Blankfein reported,
uh,
no hostile response at Columbia or where,
where,
where else did we go?
Pardon?
Princeton.
Good.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
Okay.
So let's try it.
Let's try an anonymous poll here.
We'll use the technology of humming.
And what I'd like you to do is,
if you think that a great many people who are in responsible positions at
Goldman Sachs and similar banks make more money than they really should,
you did.
Don't be shy.
And those who don't think so.
Okay.
I read that as 65,
35 in the affirmative.
Um,
at any rate,
the,
what we're gonna do today is begin with,
uh,
an informal discussion.
Uh,
looking at some of Paulos work over the,
over the years at Goldman.
Um,
whereas last time focused within the firm,
uh,
today we're going to focus on the firm as an actor in the larger world.
And a polo is going to,
going to respond to a few questions about other endeavors and then he is going
to take the,
take the mic and a lecture on the,
the case of the huge Spanish,
uh,
energy company,
and the battle for control of it.
And you'll see when he does that,
that the activities of an investment banker are a pretty challenging and
extremely complex.
Uh,
but we'll continue with.
Well,
let's start with,
do any of you own any garments from dolce
there?
Does anybody know what it is?
What pray.
Tell.
Okay.
They're a designer.
Do they just draw things or do they make and sell things?
Okay.
And are they for the value conscious shopper?
No.
Uh,
they are the inverse of Walmart.
who,
who's higher on the price schedule than them?
Paulo,
anybody?
Hermes,
Hermes may be higher,
but it's a luxury goods company.
And Paolo who dresses well,
but so far as I can tell,
doesn't care a bit about luxury goods.
Uh,
is it's chairman.
Um,
tell us about,
just in a few minutes about what the object of your roll there is and how it
relates to the CEO and the strategic challenges.
The company,
you know,
my role is,
uh,
the company don't take advantage.
It's about 23,
24 years old.
He'd want to started by the two design yet,
and by the CEO,
he has grown at Airway,
have about a 20,
25% per year.
Well,
I'd,
before the right before the credit crunch was a,
the multiples were about,
uh,
let's say 13 to 14 times a,
it'd be dot.
They can't find,
he was more or less was about,
uh,
$6 billion.
But the culture of the company has to remain like the small company.
The two designers started it.
And so the reason why we developed a friendship out of a,
I would have a chance,
they have an excellent,
uh,
CEO,
I believe it verbally in a counter.
You were,
uh,
ladies CEO's or rather than usual,
could I think she might be the only one,
only a company of that size.
She's really for me to pull one of the best CEOs I have met.
And so we developed a friendship with our first thing with Edwin,
with the two designers afterwards.
And at one point they thought that the main challenge of the company wants to
become more institutionalized.
Because if you look,
especially if you look at luxury goods companies,
few of them are institutionalized because for instance,
just to take a few Armani is not
five days.
No,
it would take up by an ice.
No.
Gucci visa institutionalized.
Help us make sure we understand what's meant by institutionalized
additional lies.
I mean,
uh,
companies where the,
let's say the corporate functions are very strong and companies where you have
culture and processes and personalities and uh,
recruitment policies and the leadership selection policies that are likely to
make the company successful over the long period.
Regardless,
all the influence and the survival of the,
so the firm,
it's strategies and the,
and the job structure,
the structure of employment responsibility becomes permanent enough to transcend
the founding group.
Yes.
Usually the best way,
usually the best way,
the best way,
one of the effective way to do it.
So he would go back to Monday.
Why don't the effective way to do it east to turn it into a public liability and
have shareholders and the discipline and the function that the public market
imposes on here.
That's the entrepreneurs kind of like to do it.
And so it's,
uh,
so it's,
it's uh,
to try to institutionalize the company in that way without turning to the public
market,
which is something that the who own us,
they own,
they own.
90% of the camp are many,
10% is owned by a few other senior managers
with a French camp.
Uh,
and uh,
and so since they don't want to access the public market making
institutionalizing company,
so such strong personalities involved not only in designing the goods,
but in the everyday,
the everyday life of the company is not easy.
So they saw that I could then I could be helpful.
So far we've done very much,
but
anyways,
a lot of fun.
I have to tell you it's a lot of them,
uh,
another uh,
industrial sector that you had a very substantial experience with his cars with
a Ford Fiat,
Volvo and General Motors.
But I got that right.
Did I miss something?
She wants to talk about taxes as well as it did to the sector that cracks and
you are taxing there with least you we used to have tracks in a fan.
Sorry.
Um,
I actually thought it thought your experience with um,
helping to bring general motors and Fiat together and then helping them to
separate themselves,
uh,
was very interesting.
And your views about the sort of informal compact that seemed at that time to
regulate the Detroit car companies and which probably wasn't a great influence
on the survivability of General Motors.
That seemed like a very interesting topic.
If you could give us a few minutes on it.
See
One of the,
one of the peculiarities of all that on the car industry worldwide,
definitely the car industry in Europe is that he's one of the few in Scully and
it hasn't been played by or capacity or at least at least the last 30 years
and one of the few industries in wage.
These overcapacity have never been taken out of the system.
But in with the players have at least until last year until the easy or survive
and eat.
This is a very peculiar situation because if you look at most,
if you look at most private industries in which there is,
there is a larger degree of private ownership and uh,
more or less the rules of capitalism apply to at least to a large extent,
you are really seldom have such a high degree over,
over capacity and the survival of all the place,
not only,
but I'm not up to date,
but let's say that after five years ago,
six years ago when I was used to be up to day capacity and being not taken off
the system but added
there is we will,
we will have to search long and hard to find a situation where it's a productive
facilities have been shot down.
And on the contrary,
we find a lot of instances in which new productive facilities had been built,
but none has been shot down.
So actually you could argue,
we'll have to look at the numbers,
but you could argue that actually over at the actually the overcapacity has gone
worse.
And uh,
players,
the players and being high,
I mean they are not stupid people.
They are conscious of the fact that they operate in an industry we cheese or
which was like we should,
I think steelies plagued by over capacity.
And so,
except for drastic reduction in the capacity,
sir,
closing down factors they have been trying to address the situation and every
possible way.
One of the ways,
one of the most of the traditional way that there'd be news as being,
uh,
different types of a joint venture and or mergers and acquisition.
One of the fair,
one of the actions that was supposed to change the face of the,
uh,
the face of the industry was the acquisition,
of Chrysler by dumb events.
But I think that,
uh,
the think that,
the,
the absorption a demon work,
well Diamler lost a lot of money and afterward Chrysler was sold to a private
equity firm.
The only case that I know of or reasonably loud of a reasonably large car
company being shutdown,
the old British Leyland,
uh,
that,
that was sold for private equity firm and laughter and the brand,
the brand,
there was a,
the brand was sold to a Chinese
European brand.
Okay.
And without getting down the details,
well,
broad details,
the compact that seem to operate between management and uh,
and labor and management of one company in management of another.
The government and government stole that album.
It was a,
it's different in different nations,
but let's say that that's be Jenna,
which is my main passion and working for them was that,
uh,
was,
they were a little incentive in vigorously addressing the situation.
We,
uh,
with the kind of action that you will be that we will be.
And that was because,
uh,
you know,
because let's take,
it takes a,
an adversary view on the relationship in the workplace.
Let's suppose in the management would have lied to close down one five.
The degree of the degree of unionization,
the degree or,
uh,
in the whole camp and they degree or relationship in counter is different than
the United States between the Union and
the degree of influence of the,
with unions on government.
And in addition,
they degree,
which the life of the company itself depends on the Gulf and that you have seen,
uh,
you have seen an example in the last credit crunch in wage and the purchase of
all new cars is the fact of subsidized by the government.
They just knew when to say it,
but it's not,
it's not new in Europe.
It's a,
as far as I'm concerned is that he's a sad wine that I've seen in Europe.
There's another class.
So you have these,
you have these very strange situation in which a management,
the union and the government become to some extent dependent on each other.
And the last thing they want to be set to offset website and these violence is
out.
No,
no extra capacity is taken off the system.
Right?
Sure.
Right.
No.
See what saying fracturing is being done.
So the how it is now,
it is now probably it was the use of chapter.
Yeah.
Huge.
Was a huge financial crisis.
And the use of chapter 11,
uh,
which has allowed,
I'm telling your personal story.
Are you worried for a fee as a manager for about 15 years?
And I worked for Goldman for about 15 years and,
uh,
in some 14 and recently in some either is one deal that I've tried to do three
times as being fia to acquisition of Paris.
And I finished.
Sweet.
Aren't you lucky?
No,
I think,
I think it's the,
I think it was one of the deals that makes more sense in the industry and these
sign pf management were successful.
But why for success,
what's successful?
Because
Chrysler was not sold by the owner back he had,
he given to them by the federal government main thing in exchange for an
industrial postdoc and practically debt free.
So it's a,
and so as you can see,
the industry changing for the game is changing because one of them,
because because of chapter 11 and because of the size of these financial crises
there,
the compact between the three play as broke,
as broken down,
totally.
Well,
same still as general
and the car industry preserving these legacy firms,
uh,
runs against the tide of creative destruction that you expect in capitalist
industry it.
And,
uh,
is that highlighted by the fact that if you go back to the beginning of the 20th
century,
there were 1200 firms making automobiles in the United States and there
obviously had to be a meltdown there because it's an industry with huge scale
economies that encourages centralization.
Tell me who is a Columbia in the,
in the United States or in France has uh,
I slapped her or change or change the landscape in kind of making your,
the last 20 years with the exception of some Europeans or our Japanese
[inaudible] Saturday productive of the Japanese and the Koreans are enforcing
some,
some changes I think.
Yeah,
let's uh,
I'm going to get off stage and let Paolo talk about an extremely complex and
interesting cross border transaction,
which centers on Spain but it involves several European countries at once.
Shell,
I would like to,
I'll get the PowerPoint up
and write tenant.
Well I wish I knew
laptop.
There we go.
Let me try to look at one case.
We cheese.
Actually
let's take it,
let's take it one step backward.
And,
uh,
there,
the case I would like to discuss is the attempt by the new management or a large
utility company ain't m which is the only electrical but not only electrical
utility company in Italy to change.
They slapped her and the characteristic of the company hotel Lee and the attempt
by the management over a period of six or seven years to turn a major utility
company depending mostly on one single nation into a different company that,
uh,
will diminish the risk by being present into several nations.
But at the same time,
that will totally change the characteristic of that camp.
And He tried to explain if you take a utility,
usually utility as very little risk
because it leaves in a regulated sector,
it makes,
uh,
it has an agreement with a regulator that they,
you lead the utility.
We may,
we make certain level of capital investment
and in exchange we'll be able to impose on the customer some tariffs.
So if you,
if you can,
if you can imagine a utility would be very,
very safe investment for the small investors.
It will be similar to a bond
that you have to do.
Capital investment,
capital investment,
every word,
our words.
So [inaudible] system and if you invest in the companies like investing in a
bond.
So if you look at utility utilities have small capital appreciation and pay high
dividends,
the new management Raynell when angel was sort of privatized,
decided that they were trying to change that completely and tried to make the
boring utility into a company that was knowing who offer more girls,
more risk,
less deep and more capital appreciation.
When you try to do that too with the giant at the time in to decide what to do
it,
I think the danger there was,
was about 40 billion to $60 billion at today's exchange rate.
It's,
it's a major task.
And uh,
the way the management,
uh,
decided to do it was changing the powder mix and getting into renewable energy,
but also in trying to start the policy or aggressive diversification moving into
other countries.
So first they need to into eastern Europe to some extent and Russia,
but one once.
One thing that you learn,
uh,
when,
when you take the helm of a $60 billion corporation is that if you try to change
the characteristic of the company by a set or small size acquisition,
you are an out of time.
Because if you are,
if our fashion or if you have a professional management team
executing as execute,
making an executing a small deal takes as much time and effort and as executing
a huge one.
And so the what is different is the amount of breast and so the management of a
Avenel start looking around at a one single move that would have changed the
company completely.
One of the air,
one of the areas in the nations where they looked at was pain.
Why it was pain first.
Spain has a first wave as generally as a first public elite.
It's usually,
I would say it's a,
it's a country where there are regulatory system,
especially for utilities.
It's very good.
It's very stable,
it's well regulated.
There is a centuries old slasher or uh,
of tariff regulation,
intelligent behavior that is very good.
And these is created as you can see in the counter that is reasonable,
reasonably small,
the presence of at least five or six utilities that are of a decent size.
And so there was,
there is room for consolidation in a market that is very attractive from the
economic point of view.
So obviously the Spain was one of the first nations where the angel management
looker.
Moreover,
as you can see,
it's through that at our cs six layers.
But when you go to electricity,
you only have two players that are very important and days,
uh,
and he got robbed.
So email the management of anal,
a very close attention to the development in the Spanish market into
opportunities opening clapped in the Spanish mark.
What happened at one point was that uh,
I don't know how familiar you are with Spanish as a political economic system.
So let me step back one second,
a VUS and give you a few and you can ask question.
By the way,
you can interrupt me and ask question anytime you want because if not it gets
very boring for you and very confusing possibly.
So
Spanish,
the Spanish political economic system from the political point of view is it's a
very stable democracy
are you tend to have full liars parties that uh,
usually occupied the government for some,
for a reasonable amount,
for a reasonable amount of time and a change orderly.
And these,
the division between the two parties,
one is the conservative party is linked with to some extent linked with the old,
the old Catholic heritage of stone and the Aza.
He's a democratic socialist party,
more or less linked with a socialist heritage of Spain,
which is also significant.
I don't know how many of you,
but I suppose most of you are familiar with the Spanish civil war of 1935,
and at the same time,
these two parties,
uh,
leave in a culture where a regional differences in regional cleavages are very
important.
These are the main characteristic of his pain.
Political political system will come to the economic system in a while.
So two large groups strongly identified with the two main tradition in the
country.
One is socialist and the other's Cassidy.
And having a,
also living in a situation in which you have a high degree of differentiation
between different regions.
Everybody knows about the Basque areas,
but at the same time you're also to consider the Catalonia,
the era where Barcelona is a beam,
striving for autonomy if not in defendant's for a very long time.
These are the characteristics of the political economic system as far as a model
of development that Spain is the Kate spade has fallen,
especially in the last 2025 years is a model of development that is largely bias
toward,
uh,
construction and real estate development.
And so,
uh,
in very entrepreneurial,
so you have,
you ever had,
especially in the late nineties and in early 2000,
the creation of a lot of very entrepreneurial,
very aggressive,
very wealthy companies.
They that,
uh,
which line of business where mostly construction and real estate,
the entrepreneurs in these companies,
you have,
you say,
what does it have to do with the utilities and what does it to do with the
opportunities often to email,
to enter into the Spanish word that has to do that.
As you can see,
one of the diversification policies used by these entrepreneurial companies that
have made most of the money on real estate and construction was to by states
into large utility companies.
Why
it's a good diversification policies.
It pays stable dividends and we saw at the beginning and plus you enter into an
industrial sector that is fractionalized.
And so assuming that there is consolidation and Monzo seven players,
you are likely to be paid a premium for the shares that you have.
So what I tried to do that is very complex and so you have to,
excuse me and you have to ask question is that they just different on it is
different from the utility sector in any country that I,
that I know you have large or you have large construction companies as minority
but significant shoulders in many of the utilities company in Spain and they are
there for tourism.
Diversification over is because you are in a very stable,
in a very stable business,
totally different from a construction and real estate.
You'll get high division for the state that you are bought and so you get a good
deal,
a good heel on your capital.
So there is more like there's likely to be consolidation and so you are likely
to be paid a premium for the share that we purchase.
So a very nice,
very nice position to be in.
But look at this for a second.
A every company in which there is for the same reason that I tried to tell you
every utility company where there is one of these construction companies,
a show that does not have a very solid shareholder base because one of the main
shoulders is there not,
not because of a commitment to that particular industry or anything,
but Jasper have been healed while it lasts.
And for selling the shares at a premium when there is consolidation.
So if you look from the point of view of someone who wants to enter the market,
you have very attractive market because the regulatory regulatory regime is very
good and you have a situation of not totally stable shareholder base in each of
these companies.
So
as everybody expected
at the end of 2005,
the fact that uh,
uh,
the fact that the structure of the industry had two main players started
changing and one of the company gas metro beside me launched and no style bead
on in Davidson County on Tuesdays counting on the fact that,
uh,
in in days or the [inaudible] being seller for the same reason that I gave you
before.
And on the fact that they were a senior juice and the economies of scale and
scope that could have been achieved or implemented by putting together gas
natural out in the in days,
the launch your style bead,
but something that they didn't count on happening immediately,
which is that the reaction to that bid
was not very friendly by two entities.
The regulators,
as you can see,
the CME and the Spanish government.
Why was not the Spanish government,
uh,
reaction favorable in first you have,
you'll have a deal that makes perfect sense from the economic and financial
point of view,
the shoulders of days are happy because they get paid a decent premium on the
stock.
The company remained.
Spanish
synergies are going to be extracted.
There is not a lot of overlapping and so there are not going to be a lot of
layoffs.
The MCU in your company will be very strong.
We're definitely in a national champion,
probably European champion.
So why doesn't gum and like it?
It happens to be that
and days a,
my Madrid based
in Gas Natura is based in Barcelona.
It also happens to be that at the same time there is a big fight in the
political arena between the government party
socialist
and the opposition party,
the conservative and one of the issues that they are fighting on is
decentralization of power within different regions and it also happens that why
are a large part of the power base of the Socialist Party is in Madrid.
A reasonably large base of the power of the Conservative Party is in Barcelona.
So oddly enough or naturally enough,
they are owning their oding.
Socialist Party sees the attempt by a pay gas company from Barcelona to try to
buy the biggest or one of the second biggest,
it depends,
I would count utility company based in Madrid as almost a political move instead
of an industrial and they just don't like it.
And so they tried to stop it.
As you can see from the statement,
they tried to stop it.
So making it difficult,
so the regulatory agency and just tried to fight it with all the weapons of
data.
Email the Italian utility company as not being the only one,
looking at the Spanish market.
If the Spanish market is that attractive as I tried to describe it to you,
that means I,
that means to someone else.
A few other people have been looking for opportunities to enter the Spanish
market and get hold of one of those Kaisers and one,
one of the companies that you're looking for that he's a German,
the German giant called Aeon.
Johann is exceedingly sophisticated company exceeding,
they are sophisticated.
They have been a leading utility for so many years.
They know all the complexities of operating in a regulated sector where he
depended on the investment you make in the towers.
So they are,
they are very sophisticated and understanding the political environment in which
you operate and which heavily influences your outcome and your choices.
So they see an opening,
they say,
wait a second,
the government doesn't like the government,
doesn't like the gas,
natural gas,
not true.
It doesn't have a lot of cash.
So it will be difficult for them to arrays.
It will be difficult for them to raise the bid.
At the same time,
they don't seem to have,
they don't seem to have a political support.
So maybe here there is a space for a foreign bidder that we table for the
shareholders it bead that is higher than the bead of gas,
natural alpha and days.
Gutsy move.
Because if you look at our style bead,
cross border in Europe in a regulated sector,
I say this was the first one,
very gutsy move,
very well structured,
very well done,
very well timed.
So you almost,
and as you'll notice,
the BV significantly higher than the previous one 27.
We see the 21 year olds
and
in a very,
in a very sophisticated way,
which is,
which is worse than the company that you own is uh,
they also start,
is sophisticated labile with the European Commission
because they believe that the main threat is not another leader.
The main site is the Spanish government doesn't want,
I'm Joe,
it doesn't belong to a German UTP own deleting,
championing.
By the way,
there's no reason why if they didn't like if they didn't like the Barcelona who
all need lighter,
the uh,
why should they like I remember when you experience cause based in there or
somewhere.
But I don't remember.
I think is Nia,
Nia,
Frankfurt.
I think he's near Frankfurt,
but awesome.
That's it goes,
you're right.
So you want to start lobbying the European Commission and hopes to have an
opening by the German regulators.
They don't been in Greeley.
No big opposition comes,
but in our opinion,
a really dazzle con and and the Spanish government,
uh,
in their twenties,
Gavin lint spalls
our IP soul II or Billy Luke said the ownership so active in days,
it seems that it had a lot of sellers.
So it says,
okay,
these are going to be a financial side.
It,
he just upped the ante.
I raised,
my bid was 34,
34 euros per share.
Significant significantly I,
yeah.
Then the offer by gas network
and they think that they have,
and they seem to,
they have a winning hand,
you know,
the show.
They have all the resources.
I think that that,
I seem to remember that that time he on has cash on the balance sheet for about
a hundred billion of these peanuts crosswalk 40,
32.
Again,
they don't,
they don't go anywhere and they get stolen
at that point.
Emails,
it has been watching to see the way she sees an opportunity
and he's a beaten by gas math where uh,
and that that doesn't seem to go anywhere he calls or political position.
And because it's cheap
now he's a bead by the leading European champion or utility,
but he's a lot richer in,
can become a lot richer but doesn't go anywhere code.
The Spanish government is a lactide who salad or to have wine are one of the
utilities,
one of the,
one of the national champions and up in German hands.
So Emile sees an opening and a strategy based on three variables.
One,
they say maybe we can pay as much as you know,
we don't have the same cash on the balance sheet but we've not done so we can,
we can try to fight it on that.
Second is we might be more acceptable.
Who's the Spanish government?
And that's true.
That's needs to be found out and discern news.
And these is really,
in my opinion,
the winning these really the winning exceptional [inaudible].
They say,
why should we buy off those construction companies or the biggest construction
company that are,
that are using the capital that can be our ally,
you know,
locking the situation.
So why would we try to buy them out?
Why don't we simply go and talk to the interpreter?
This,
this construction company is usually one entrepreneur for each camp.
Why don't we go and talk to the interpreter and see what do you want?
One calf will give it,
do you want a piece of the company?
We would make a deal with you
what we want.
So oddly,
not often,
naturally.
Now the interpreter says,
no,
no.
The reason why I'm here is because I want to diversify my risk.
I want a significant opportunities to girls to grow.
And so what I really want is not cash,
but he's a piece of in days.
And so in l says,
okay,
uh,
let's discuss
a
rational enough,
the interpreneur,
which is actual owner stores.
So ANUMs tried to force is in and that's something very unusual in a very,
very unusual in a cross border take over.
That company goes into the market
and buys and that on Mondays I in the mark,
which according to Spanish,
which according to spending this regulation we can do and they anal is not
launch a Bdm,
Huh.
It's someone coming out of the left field.
So the going to the market and they buy 10%
at 39 years per share,
higher than higher than the beat or the beat by young.
At that point they sit around the table with the entrepreneur and say see,
we are very serious.
So we are either going either we are going to buy this company of or Ian is
going to buy or we make a d in the together.
We buy.
So long negotiation,
long negotiations,
start with the,
with the interpreter and at the end,
uh,
indeed in this negotiation,
anal again the intrepreneur stores,
the gang are tied to get more so anal again decide to be aggressive and that was
an equity swap for four.
No remain for remaining 14% or 1490 9% of the capital,
which is the maximum permitted under Spanish regulation and it tells the
entrepreneurs,
I see we are here to stay.
We now own 25% of the company.
You won't get,
we own more than you do.
You will not get worried about at the same time they show you on and they own
25% and so that they are possibly in the position to block
the takeoff.
So this is the back.
This is a battle being fought or two from one.
The only opportunity when in Al rightly decides is to make a deal with
interpreter too.
At the same time,
they have to fight the offer by Aeon,
which as you can,
as you can see,
increases
his offer who forties 40 years for sure.
At the same time,
email has been negotiating with interpreter.
Angel has been negotiating with an entrepreneur and they signed a deal in which
25% is going to be owned directly by anal,
but 51% of the shares are going to be owned by a joint venture company made by
[inaudible].
And the entrepreneur who is a Shona where the intrepreneurs 51%
and the entrepreneur who is scared about being trapped into a situation there is
not liquid.
Also ask also negotiate with Angela or I to put to put to anal his own shares
for his own shares in uh,
in,
in data for the same price that uh,
uh,
it has been negotiating the 41 14 one years pressure as you have seen.
Uh,
sorry,
I moved to as you seeing a final,
the final battle is long by is worn by amen.
He made a deal with the on on the other side and when to your honor is going to
be sold about $10 billion last of the 10 billion euros of acid.
And so he also gets a foothold in the Spanish market,
bought 10 days or stays more or less what it is and the situation is Aina.
See on that we actually all know has a right of poops.
Bueno for the shares that they own it.
Am I going too fast?
No,
you're doing fine,
right?
You've only got about three or four minutes left.
I the last day of the rest is just the endos.
No.
So the situation is that they end days that he on Poles and then days,
uh,
is now owned by email and actually honor.
Now in the meantime,
what happens in the,
what happens in the world,
the world happens that uh,
there is a credit crunch,
which in the case of Spain overlaps.
We've a very severe downturn in construction and real estate.
You have,
we need to differentiate here between defined between different characters.
You have to seem that their reliance on debt and Rli on some construction and
real estate in the case of Spain was so high that
why are in your house you have an unemployment rate is below 10% and in the
state one that he's tend to assign in Spain you have an unemployment rate,
which is 24%
white county.
So they hold Modelo development of the Spanish economy is in doubt or he's in
crisis because of the severe crisis in construction and real estate is easy.
You have to add that.
Most of the companies that I've been operating there,
including a show at Shauna,
the [inaudible],
hey been buying shares.
We use the loans by the Spanish banks.
So not only you have the collapse in the prices of the real estate asset,
you will have also the travel in the refinancing the loan that,
that'd be mine either that's being borrowed by the,
uh,
my department,
my day of construction companies.
So for instance,
a narrative arc now stop trying to legal financial traffic.
It starts early legal,
financial troubles that are so big.
I probably only security,
like he came there,
he can give the bags or renewing the level that they have extended to is the
fruits of the 25% or 10 days or that he owns or
25 point something to Aina
and that could by the way is at a price that is the price of the bid,
which was 41 at the same time.
The price of that at the same time the price of the shares in the market have
gone down to 24 25 I don't know,
between 2025 across mainland.
So Emile seize the opportunity,
glad to get control of all of the injuries are shares,
approaches the interpreneur and says okay you have that ride put for 2011 why
don't we negotiate a situation in which we will pay you less than for the one
for sure
you will get some assets and we will get the 25% we were getting,
we were getting a 25% of the shelves,
so there is a,
there is an extensive negotiation
and anal and stop by the 25% of at Shauna dissolving the joint venture and
getting control of 92% days.
However you can see what this does playing the bead was largely based on that
the purchaser,
we accelerated purchase of the shares as increased the debt.
So now anal time itself selfless
when he in $23 billion market cap equity market cap from $65 billion.
So the change in the change that the management one team has occurred,
but what happened is that because of the way it has been managed and because of
the circumstances,
there is a huge load of that.
On the company and it is still that they wanted to have a more risky company
with higher,
with the higher potential girls.
But the investors are not very happy about having about having invested in
company,
which the equity that way could be a ratio is three to one or 3.2 to one.
So any other things that uh,
uh,
capital in order to Nema dividend or reduction and the capital increase,
what is the problem?
The problem is nothing that probably there is,
there is enough room,
we advise them.
There isn't often there's an appetite in the market to do a capital in
victories,
but the problem is that the Italian government directly through the Trevor,
he's pumps 32% Reyna.
And as you know,
these are not your European and American government these days are saddled with
a large amount of that they will have to repay.
So at the level of the Italian government,
there is very little appetite for subscribing the rights issue.
The other hand,
there is very little appetite for beans IUT and made a nail into a totally
public company because when you own more than 70% according to Italian,
a lot more or less dominate 100% of the board of 90% of the book.
So they used the final,
the final effort by the management.
He's a,
he's a negotiation this time,
not with the Spanish government,
but we did tell you in government,
in order to try to convince the government to let the capital please go forward
and either be di you do with those subscribers.
And uh,
and this is not going to send it to the class,
but the government eventually gave up and found a way in which they could
subscribe to the capital increase without increasing the government deficits
other country.
Thanks Paolo.
We look forward to having.